- [Paige] Hello grammarians, hello David.
- [David] Hello Paige.
- [Paige] So today we're gonna
talk about Plural Possession.
Meaning when more than one
person, or thing, or animal,
owns something else.
And this, like most other
types of possession,
tends to involve apostrophes.
- [David] Makes sense, checks out.
- [Paige] Yeah, cool.
- [David] So it's just
apostrophe, S, right?
Like, I mean, why are we
even making this video?
- [Paige] Well, no.
- [David] Oh.
- [Paige] Apostrophe, S,
is a rule that applies when
the possessive noun is singular.
So for example, the dog's bone.
Right, that's one dog's bone.
- [David] One singular
dog possessing one bone.
- [Paige] Exactly.
- [David] What if I
wanted to talk about like,
five dogs' bones?
Like they had a big old pile of bones?
- [Paige] Right, so that is a case where
we will not use apostrophe, S.
- [David] What?
- [Paige] I'm sorry to disappoint.
- [David] I'm not disappointed,
I'm just surprised.
Not actually surprised,
that's just a stage trick.
- [Paige] So, if we're
talking about five dogs,
and their bones,
we say five dogs, apostrophe, bones,
and there's no S after the apostrophe.
- [David] So it goes S, apostrophe?
So we have the S for the plural,
and then an apostrophe for possession,
but not a second S for possession?
- [Paige] Right, we don't want like,
the dogs's bones.
- [David] Okay.
Okay, but the apostrophe
at the end isn't about
there being multiple bones, right?
It's about there being multiple dogs?
- [Paige] Yeah, so even
if it's multiple dogs,
and they're possessing a singular thing,
- [David] So if five dogs
all had the same favorite
dog park.
- [Paige] Right, because
it's the best dog park
in the world.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] So in that case
you would say something like,
the dogs' favorite park.
Right, park is still
singular, but dogs' is plural.
So that's why it's just
apostrophe, and no S afterwards.
- [David] So this also only
applies to plural nouns that
end in S, right?
So if I'm talking about one
of our irregular plural nouns,
like mice,
or geese,
or men, or women,
I would still add apostrophe, S, right?
Like, okay, so I'm imagining
a department store,
and there's a men's
section, a women's section,
and a mice's section.
- [Paige] (laughs) Okay,
that is an interesting
department store.
- [David] Well it doesn't
take up that much floor space
for the mouse section.
So, I get that if there's
more than one dog,
it's D-O-G-S, apostrophe.
If it's a plural irregular
noun that doesn't end in S,
then it's still just apostrophe, S,
like regular possession.
What about family names?
- [Paige] Oh, okay,
that's a good question.
So, let's say there's a family
with the last name, Harper.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] And I am going to
visit the Harpers' house.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] Right, so that's
the house that belongs to
all of the Harpers, the Harper family.
- [David] Okay, so that seems
pretty straight forward,
but what if we're talking
about a name that ends in S?
Like Burns?
- [Paige] Okay, yeah.
That can make things a
little bit complicated.
The way that names that
end in S become plural is
by adding ES to the end of them.
So Burns becomes Burnses.
- [David] And so Burnses,
without the apostrophe,
is how I would refer to that
family unit in total also.
Right, like it's Mr Burns and the Burnses?
Or Dr Jones and the Joneses?
- [Paige] Exactly.
- [David] Okay.
- [Paige] So then when you
wanna make that possessive,
as in, the Burnses' house,
you make it plural by adding that ES,
and then put the apostrophe after that.
- [David] Cool, so plural
things that end in S
don't have a second S
after the apostrophe?
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] But irregular plurals,
like men, women, mice, do?
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] Thank you, Paige.
- [Paige] You're welcome.
You can learn anything.
- [David] David out.
- [Paige] Paige out.